بعد يومي عمل النمو وطويل في واحده من
اكبر مستشفيات برلين تعود الممرضه سالي
منهكه الى منزلها ولكن رغم ذلك فهي غير
قادره على الاسترخاء الاضاءه في منزلها
خافته فهي تحاول تقليل قدر الامكان من
مصروف الكهربائي والغاز فالقلق دائما من
فواتير التدفئه التي تقول انها مضطره
لتشغيلها بسبب ابنتها وان بالحد الادنى
عربي
المستطاع ولكن الوضع بشكل عام ليس جيدا
لان على المرء دائما ان يكون حذرا
باستخدام التدفئه والكهرباء والى اي مدى
ودائما هناك تفكير بالتوفير رغم انني اعمل
بدوام كامل
الكثير من الالمان باتو مثل سالي يقتصدون
في التدفئه ربما ليس تجاوبا مع مطالب
السياسيين اكثر منه خوفا من الفواتير
الباهضه فرغ ما تحذيرات السياسيين من
ضروره الاقتصادي في استخدام الغاز يرى
خبراء بان المانيا ليس لديها ما تخشاه على
الاقل هذا الشتاء لانها لم تعتمد على
الغاز الروسي في ملء خزانتها
ارتفع استهلاك الغاز بشكل كبير وهذا ما
دفع المسؤولين لمطالبه الجميع المواطنين
والشركات بترشيد استهلاك الغاز ولكن عموما
امدادات الغاز في المانيا مضمونه على مدار
اشهر على مدى هذا الشتاء
والفتح والفتره القادمه
ان هذا العام عيد الميلاد وراس السنه ليس
كسابقته رغم ان المدينه تزينت كالماضي
وبالنسبه لسالي فانا تراجع على القدره
الشرائيه يعني بانها غير قادره على
الاحتفال بالعيد كما في الماضي والا شراء
الهدايا بالشكل نفسها زوخه انا احاولوا ان
يكون لدي مزاج جيد احيانا انجح احيانا له
لا يمكنني القول انني اتطلع جدا للعيد اجد
الوضع الحالي مروع حقيقه
راغده العربيه